lots of people die in the suicide squad
dc gave writer director jim's gun
blanket permission to kill
any character he wanted and he made good
use of that freedom
here's a list of the major deaths in
gunn's gory romp
black guard captain boomerang tdk
javelin mongal
and savant all die in the beach assault
this is the first version of task force
x assembled for the movie and they all
die like jabronies in the first 15
minutes
blackguard sells the squadmates out to
the hostels and his reward is getting
his own face blown off
almost everyone else on the beach dies
from some variation of being shot
and or blown up savant is an exception
his cranial bomb is detonated by amanda
waller after he tries to run away from
the mission
during a press event warner brothers
held for the suicide squad actor juan
diego bodo said
the character that i play general sylvia
luna he is the new ruler of this
cordo maltese island and he is obsessed
with two things
his collection of rainbow lorikeets and
harley quinn
and those two obsessions will determine
his fate eventually
he had to play it a little koi at the
time with the last bit but we have no
need for coins now
silvia luna dies in the suicide squad
silvio
specifically seeks out harley quinn and
brings her to his palatial estate
where he says he sees her as the
embodiment of american rebellion
upon spending a single glorious day with
harley he proposes marriage and lays out
his plans for rule unfortunately for him
mentioning that those plans involve
killing civilians and children is
too much of a red flag harley shoots
silvio explaining that after her
past relationships she just can't handle
certain toxic elements
dc comic's character ratcatcher's
appearance in the suicide squad is brief
and
exists entirely in memory but it's
accurate to say that his character
played by taiko atiti dies in this movie
we learn his story during a flashback
clio aka ratcatcher 2 and her father
grew up on the streets of portugal aided
entirely by his father's ability to
communicate with rats through technology
the rats were able to provide them with
anything they needed
unfortunately he was also a drug addict
and died of an overdose
this death led cleo to take his rat wand
and also his name
she moved to america but was sentenced
to bel rev for armed robbery after the
rats were declared weapons
we only hear ratcatcher 1 speak roughly
2 sentences toward the end of the film
in another flashback
but it's one of the movie's most
emotional moments leaving the audience
with the idea that if something as vile
as a rat can find a place in the world
anyone can no death in the suicide squad
comes as a
bigger shock than that of rick flagg
it's his nobility that does him in when
he discovers the depth of the us
government's involvement with the
captivity of and research into starro
he decides to take a hard drive and tell
the world waller however has known about
this all along and has a backup plan
peacemaker she gives peacemaker specific
instructions to make sure the
information
didn't leave the facility flag and
peacemaker fight
and are for the most part evenly matched
at least until peacemaker manages to
fatally stab
flag in the heart the only unambiguous
hero in task force x
dies but not before alerting peacemaker
that ratcatcher 2
saw the whole thing one of james gunn's
most significant achievements in the
suicide squad
is making a tragic and sympathetic
figure out of polka dot men
and making the characters equally stupid
death devastating
abner krill's backstory is that his
polka dot powers are the result of an
interdimensional
infection once set up by his scientist
mother he resents his mother
so much that he sees every possible
enemy
that is to say everyone as her he's
self-conscious about his infection
and his powers and just about begs for
death
we're all gonna die i hope so during the
final battle with starro bloodsport has
pointed instructions for polka dot man
pretend the giant starfish terrorizing
the city
is his mother krill manages to inflict
massive damage with his polka dots
he does throw polka dots at people but
just when he's
finally feeling confident about his
powers his abilities
and his place in the world he gets
crushed literally
the thinker is the foremost expert on
starro having conducted research on the
giant alien mind controlling starfish
for years
he makes an uneasy alliance with the new
regime on cordo maltese after the coup
both of these things
lead to this death one inevitable as it
is brutal
task force x captures the thinker and
escorts him to yodenheim
while there task force x sees staro for
the first time and
just as damningly all the people starro
controls
the thinker reveals staro's origins the
research he spent
decades conducting and the fact that the
us was in on it all along
after jodenheim explodes starro is freed
and his first order of business is
dealing with his captor the thinker begs
for his life but it's no use
as starro rips the scientist lim from
lim
poor poor milton he isn't a hero
he isn't a villain he isn't even an
anti-hero he's
just some dude he gets swept up with
task force x and drives them from point
a to point b
albeit with more than a few unplanned
stops between a and b
he even helps with several of their
schemes up to and including planting
bombs at jodenheim
during a firefight on the upper floors
of jurgenheim milton gets killed in the
crossfire
to add to the dignity of his death some
of the team doesn't even know he's with
them
they assume he's back at the van harley
meanwhile can't remember milton's name
at least until she sees the body the
perils of being just a normal guy
in a world of metahumans general matteo
suarez
isn't just the right-hand man for silvio
luna he's the muscle
a respected and feared military leader
he also has his own leadership
aspirations and functionally takes
control of the government after luna's
death he's shown to be
far more brutal than sylvia but he gets
karmic payback
and a half for everything he's done one
word reaches him that task force x is at
jodenheim
he personally leads the army assaulting
the tower he and his men survive the
explosion but they don't
survive starro finally free star kills
or
mind controls almost the entire quarto
maltese military including suarez who
learns the hard way
not to mess with intergalactic starfish
he dies
like the rest of his men confused and
despondent
as the secret his government hid stops
being a secret
in the least subtle way possible an
intergalactic starfish
and also perhaps the most dangerous evil
force in the dc eu
captured by astronauts who only found
out about his mind control ability after
he spits some offspring at them
sorrow was brought to earth for research
understandably being kept in captivity
for decades leaves him with something of
a grudge against humanity
on top of his already existing
conquering urges
long kept a secret by both the us and
the court of maltese governments
starro makes himself known to the world
in a big way after finally escaping from
judenheim
after a thrilling battle during which
bloodsport finally shows his medal as a
leader
starro is defeated his eye is pierced by
harley as rats
jump in and tear his innards to shreds
task force
x become heroes and end up in the rarest
of all situations
having leverage over amanda waller check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
suicide squad are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one